Delighted to be here and to talk to you about a subject near to my heart which is beauty.
Now, this is an extremely complicated subject.
In part, because the things that we call beautiful are so different.
I mean, just think of the sheer variety:...
...A baby's face,...
...Berlioz's Harold in Italy,...
...movies like "The Wizard of Oz" or the plays of Chekhov,...
...a Central California landscape,...
...a Hokusai view of Mount Fuji,...
...Der Rosenkavalier,...
...a stunning match-winning goal in a World Cup soccer match,...
...Van Gogh's Starry Night,...
...a Jane Austen novel,...
...Fred Astaire dancing across the screen.
This brief list includes human beings, natural landforms,...
...works of art, and skilled human actions.
An account that explains the presence of beauty in everything on this list is not going to be easy.
I can however, give you at least a taste...
...of what I regard as the most powerful theory of beauty we yet have.
This theory comes from an expert on barnacles, and worms, and pigeon breeding.
And you know who I mean, Charles Darwin.
We find beauty in something done well.
So, the next time you pass by a jewelry shop window displaying a beautifully cut teardrop-shaped stone,...
...don't be so sure it's just your culture telling you that sparkling jewel is beautiful.
Your distant ancestors loved that shape...
...and found beauty in the skill needed to make it,...
...even before they could put their love into words.